Don: Obrigado por ter vindo.
Este é o painel da Venture Capital
e começamos com este [indistinct].
E tenho tres pessoas destacadas aquí
para responder às nossas perguntas.
Espero ter um pouco de tempo no final
para voces fazerem umas perguntas
e para as painelistas responderem.
Vou fazer isso um pouquinho diferente.
Vou fazer as perguntas em inglês,
mas vão responder em português
para que voces entendam melhor
o que vão dizer.
Bem, para mim vai ser um desafio
porque não falo português,
mas está bom.
É melhor assim.
Vamos começar com as apresentações.
Se cada um de voces pode se apresentar --
dois minutos -- o que é que você faz.
Alex: Well, my name is Alex Tabor.
I'm Brazilian,
but I grew up overseas,
That's why my accent is strange.
I grew up in Asia, India,
Pakistan, Indonesia, [inaudible].
I studied in California,
Los Angeles, the United States.
I graduated in 2003.
I came to Brazil to [inaudible]
to begin [inaudible]
we solved internet systems problems
for large companies
in the United States and in England
and then we worked for a business
called Power Media;
that had outside power [inaudible] or
[inaudible] that was real big at the time
and we were growing with
the wave of social networks.
We raised the investment of [?FJ],
one of the biggest Venture Capital
businesses in the United States [inaudible].
And we left there... I learned a lot there
[inaudible], architecture, scalable
software, email-delivered billing.
All of the parts of the internet
came out of there. And with
a friend of mine, Júlio Vasconcelos,
we decided to set up an internet company
for the domestic market
here in Brazil.
We tested out several ideas.
We developed some pilot programs
to check whether the idea was viable,
and we ended up making Fisherbun
that grew a lot in 7 months.
We now have 200 employees.
... one of the biggest websites here in Brazil
now [inaudible] is growing quickly.
Eric: My name is Eric Archer.
I'm one of the founding partners
of Monacir Capital,
It's a Venture Capital business
in the beginning stages.
We focus on investments for businesses
that are starting in the consumer sectors
of the internet
consumer services using the internet,
and educational technologies.
We focus on these two sectors.
We founded [Monacir] in 2005.
We began to invest at the end of 2006.
Now we have a portfolio
of 10 investments;
and we believe that we are in
an exciting time in Brazil:
the creation of new businesses
in venture capital.
My background:
I worked at [inaudible] for a while,
in the 15th Strategic Advisory
here in Brazil and in the U.S.
then I worked at General Atlantic,
which is a venture capital
and private equity business...
it does both.
While I worked there
I did both things.
I also had [inaudible]
several businesses invested
in the internet, ETrade, Priceline
[inaudible] at the time [inaudible]
first assistance.
And it was there at General Atlantic
working in the U.S.
that I realized that what I wanted
to do was initial stages,
venture capital, initial stages
are two very different markets.
they are [investment] businesses
that are beginning to invest
in already-established [inaudible].
The opportunity that we see
here today.
then I came back to Brazil.
my partner and I, Fabrício,
created Monacir
and since then, I've been doing [inaudible].
Humberto: Good afternoon. My
name is Humberto Matsuda.
I'm a partner in Performing Investments
a venture capital firm
that has almost two [inaudible]
to connect to businesses,
with [inaudible] connect bigger
and all the activity I am responsible for
investments
and small businesses and medium-
sized businesses
and start-ups,
uh,
Our main characteristic is that
we don't invest in only
very small businesses,
lots of times still on paper or an idea
but we help cultivate and
build the business. This is a
model where we begin a business
independently from investments;
and it can be any business
to create a business model.
To shape its product,
identify the principle characteristics
of the business
it wants to develop,
what it wants to have the future.
Help design the business plan
and at the same time
if the business manages to aquire
these characteristics,
we invest up to $5 million reais
in each business.
Our focus in investing today
isn't limited to
information;
but we also invest
in biotechnology
nanotechnology, medical applications
infra-[inaudible] technology, and we've
done a lot of interactive
and creative work with businesses.
We prefer to
[inaudible] is always the time
that a business is going to define
what it will do,
how it wants to work
so in that sense, we have
an actionable [inaudible] moment.
We help build the business,
and at the same time
provide financial resources
and a series of services to help
the business grow, from lawyers
accountants [ ] business marketing,
public relations...
And, once successful,
later even working to find investors
and consequently strengthening
the project long before
it begins [inaudible].
Don: Está bom. Tenho
ums fones de ouvido aquí
para que eu possa entender
o que dizem desde o descanso.
Eric, antes falamos de
empreendedores diferentes.
Então o empresário de alto impacto e
o com um negócio tipo estilo de vida.
Você pode explicar o que quer dizer?
Quais são as diferenças e
quais voce aconselha?
Eric: We talked about...
before this panel,
when we talked a little about
types of entrepreneurs,
because when you talk about
entrepreneurs,
we talk a lot in Brazil
that the leading [inaudible] entrepreneurs,
entrepreneurs want
to be entrepreneurs
the beginning of an interesting cycle
where people are very [inaudible]
to be entrepreneurs as a viable
alternative on this road,
that never was, never happened in Brazil.
And that's a plus,
the venture capital industry will only
exist if we have good entrepreneurs.
so our chat revolved around
those questions
we say entrepreneurs
like it was an umbrella.
Something like... like all entrepreneurs
are the same kind.
And the work at Venture Capital-
our work in looking for
investment opportunities-
is to look for the right teams
the right coaches,
and to do that we have to
we use our perspective with
respect to kinds of entrepreneurs
segments of entrepreneurs.
and it's very important that here we have
different entrepreneurs this time
... thinking about ...
you always would complain about
that type of entrepreneur [inaudible].
Because, depending on the type
of entrepreneur that you are,
you'll work and build
a certain kind of business
and that business can be compatible
with a Venture Capital investment
or not.
That first generic segment
of lifestyle and high impact ones:
there's no problem with the
entrepreneur interested in lifestyle,
or entrepreneurs interested in
a high-impact lifestyle.
It's neither right nor wrong;
they're just two different things.
An entrepreneur working on
lifestyle doesn't necessarily
want to change the world;
he wants to have a good business
that offers a high-quality product
or service that grows;
but he doesn't necessarily want
to create a million-dollar business.
He'll be happy if it earns
10 or 20 million and gets a
a good profit return
for the partners
and he won't necessarily have
that truly personal incentive
to grow the business
to make the business grow.
But it's interesting.
We have to... I think there are great
entrepreneurs of that kind
in Brazil; they [inaudible]
their [inaudible].
Now, an entrepreneur
that Venture Capital is looking for
is a high-impact entrepreneur,
an entrepreneur that
wants to revolutionize the market.
He wants to build a great business
and structurally change the market,
how the market works.
[inaudible] change through its product,
or even its impact
on millions of people's lives
and create a very large business.
Because Venture Capital's risk
the investor
the extra finance that's invested
in this initial stage
has to be balanced against
a disproportional return.
That risk is disproportional.
And then what happens?
The high impact entrepreneur,
is the one who will align himself
with the venture capital investor.
And that alignment of the business,
at its foundation, if you analyze
the businesses that work out....
with the entrepreneur-investor
relationship...
are businesses where
that alignment is very close.
Where the investors and entrepreneurs
think the same way,
with the same objectives.
That want to build the same thing,
and get out of the investment
at the same time.
So both sides -
this is an important message -
we here,
Humberto talked about this, too-
but when we talk
with teams
and meet entrepreneurs
you have to understand
spending time with them
to see if it makes sense
to do some kind of investment.
The same thing is important
on the part of the entrepreneur
because he...
he also does his own job
to find out if this is the kind of investor
that wants for his business
that is really everything
and it's a [inaudible] road.
Don: Então, Humberto, você investe
nos empresários de estágio inicial?
É claro para eles que quando você
começa que estarão num negócio
ou num negócio de lifestyle?
Você ajuda eles?
Humberto: In reality, no
one day, we
in spite of the fact that Eric posed
that question very well...
in practice, it's very difficult
to separate those two characteristics
talking with someone for 5 minutes.
In the process of analysis,
we focus mainly
on the people involved.
Eric and I, both,
we won't... we'll avoid investing
in projects where the people involved
don't have those qualities,
that drive to create something
really revolutionary...
but simply talking about
the essence of one or the other
is much easier than clearly
identifying those qualities in people.
Because lots of times
the entrepreneur himself doesn't know
what kind of entrepreneur he is.
And the analysis of the market,
the analysis of its potential,
making projections, are ways to evaluate
those matters that border on art.
They aren't necessarily
exact sciences.
So when we begin
to work with a company
we have to see some potential,
but not necessarily
that that business is going to
be successful, or reach a degree of
certainty that that's possible;
and that's why we begin
to work with businesses
even before knowing
if we are going to invest in them.
When a business attains
these qualities
that's when Performa's funds invest.
But if a business doesn't attain
those qualities,
it's also not necessarily
a problem.
That just means that while it doesn't have
all the qualities we're looking for,
the investement, per se,
won't happen.
So from the perspecitve
of the practice of what we do,
we try to work with a business
for the longest time possible
and available, because
the truth is that
our scarcest resource is time.
So we have to optimize
and allocate this time
in an efficient way.
We end up having to take care of
building the business
building up the credit
that the fund wants to invest...
in a way that it will acquire
those qualities.
If the company can't do that,
that also doesn't mean that
it's a bad business.
It only means that there's a disconnect
between Venture Capital's business
and that company's business.
If there's that disconnect,
it's an example of what
Eric talked about, a lack of alignment.
And that's the worst scenario
for any type of investment...
to get out there,
after money was put into the company,
after we've spent a lot of time
one, two...
three years working together,
and to discover that
we don't want the same thing.
That's the surest factor
for an unsuccessful investment.
Don: Então, Alex, você já foi
empreendedor algumas vezes.
Foram seus primeiros esforços
os que diríamos
mais pequenos, ou um tipo lifestyle
e depois, de mais alto impacto?
É possível ser um empreendedor
lifestyle e de alto impacto ao mesmo tempo?
Alex: Yes! I think that it all
depends on the opportunity.
And I also... if you find a good idea
to follow up on,
to develop,
to make it grow quickly,
you go after it and make it happen.
When I started
I didn't have experience.
I didn't know enough to
manage taking care of all the aspects
of an internet network.
So I began first with costing
and I learned several things, platform
and software,
working on a team.
These things are important,
but for a web business today
there are complicated things
and it's good to examine deeply
a little before
starting a business - in the field.
I mentioned email,
delivery building...
It's very complicated if you don't know
how to scale your software...
to be able to double,
and double, and double
many times without having to
rebuild everything.
It's difficult to grow
at a fast pace.
My second experience
was not as an entrepreneur
who started a company.
I joined one that already
had 50 employees.
I helped with the venture around
but I...
the best thing about my participation
in that company...
was that I managed to work with
infrastructure, software, and email.
All of those parts -
in order to be ready when I left
to begin my company,
to be ready to anticipate
and prepare for everything,
for all those problems I'd face
So that's why it's important
to first educate yourself well
and later join with someone
who is good at sales, marketing.
With only 2 people --
you can even have 3, if you call in
another technical friend.
If you manage to develop
a low-cost pilot program
you can really bank on
a business like that
on the internet these days it's
very cheap to start a new product
to create a new product.
So I think the best thing
is to sit there,
and develop something tangible
that brings results;
and that you can measure its impact
and see that it can really grow a lot,
and that's when you should
go there and look for capital
to hire more people and
buy advertising.
Build up more infrastructure
if, at that time, you've proven
your set-up
you should go get the money
to invest in it, and make...
and make it grow as fast as possible.
Don: Então nos Estados Unidos, os
startups tem um sócio técnico
e um sócio de negócios ou marketing.
Então você é um sócio técnico,
Como encontrou seu sócio de negócios?
Ou, para o pessoal da audiencia
que provavelment são técnicos
como encontram outro sócio
para trabalhar junto com eles?
Alex: Well, it's very easy.
You're sitting on a plane
there's a guy sitting next to you,
and you talk to him
ha ha ha.
That's how I met Júlio
ha ha ha
I never talk with anyone on planes
but in that case...
by chance
we began to chat
and he grew up in
many places, like I did.
We were studying at Stanford
with several of
my childhood friends.
We got to be friends
and kept talking.
So the first tip is this
talk to the guy next to you
ha ha ha.
on the plane. But speaking seriously,
a way to make contacts
through the...
the faculty is a great place
to make them.
Also at work.
Thre are people in the same company
who have other qualities,
you get along well with them
and that's very important.
One thing is to find the right person
another is that you have to
get along with each other.
Because you're going spend long nights
working every day together
for many months.
So you have to be
not only a competent person
but you have to
get along well together.
Don: Vamos dizer que tenho uma
ideia ótima para um negócio.
Como vou encontrar você?
Como você sabe aonde estou?
Ou como vou chegar para você?
Eric: That's a matter of...
It's really important to understand that
there are many more opportunities
or ther are many more
entrepreneurs looking for funding
looking for funding
than
mainly in Brazil
than companies looking
to invest.
I think it's a rule
anywhere.
The Venture Capital business has to
be very efficient with their time.
The only resource we have
is time, is time on the team.
So we have to
shoot on target.
And go after opportunities
that make sense.
We'd love to meet as many
entrepreneurs as possible,
but if we stop and say,
no, let's put
an ad in a newspaper
put up a website
take all
business plans
that doesn't work for us.
So,
we specifically
have a very proactive strategy
of going after businesses
that we think
are interesting.
We keep our eyes open
we stay tuned in to the market
to maket sectors
that we like.
We follow the movements
in those market sectors.
and we try to meet with
business entrepreneurs
that we see potential in
soon thereafter. I think that the art
of Venture Capital is that you go after it;
you are proactive.
Because if you stay in the office
and say I'm going to hold or
have meetings with
500 entrepreneurs each month
that's not how you'll find
the best opportunities.
We tend to,
our strategy is
is not, let's say,
low-profile
of us not being
really exposed.
Because we understand
that entrepreneurs have
few alternatives in Brazil.
So we go after them.
A typical case is the case of Bobox,
which is one of the businesses
in our portfolio
we met Botox at
TechCrunch in 2007.
Marco Gomes' project came out of it
It was the first Brazilian company -
maybe it was the second -
I can never remember...
but I think it was the first company,
or Brazilian project, that
came out of TechCrunch.
We'd already been following TechCrunch
When we saw
what came out of that company,
it was a little like
who are these guys?
Let's get to know them.
We called, it was a project
that Marco Gomes
and his partner at the time
were working off-hours on.
We followed up, talked,
we liked them a lot,
and we made the investment.
We're extra happy
with that investment.
That was a very typical example
of what we like to do.
With the message,
I'd say, to an entrepreneur
who wants to talk to
Venture Capital, really,
the best route is
to do good work.
Today, entry costs
the cost for you to set up
a product is low
on the internet, I'm saying -
There are other sectors
where it's different.
But to do good work,
To put your company in place
or to set up your product
to get working
you'll attract the attention of
of the Venture Capitals -
if you do good work.
That's the best way.
Or through a qualified network
that you know,
or that someone can point you to.
Normally, cold calls -
Calls to try
to demonstrate something
without one of these two things
there's a lot less efficiency
on both sides.
Don: Então, Humberto,
você trabalha com as fases iniciais
das empresas.
Como é que você encontra eles
ou eles encontram você?
Humberto: In our case, it was
from the point of view
of financing, specifically
it's very much like the way
Monarchis works.
But before the financing,
there's the process
of structuring the business
so that we can invest.
So at that point
at that point specifically,
it's obviously difficult for us
to identify a project
when it's still on paper
when it's an idea
or just a PowerPoint.
What do we do then?
We try to respond,
listen to as many initiatives
as possible
that come into contact
with us in the following way.
We get our bearings and beg
for the love of God
that the entrepreneurs
know a little bit more
about the investors
they want to talk to.
If you know the kind of investor
you need
what kind of investor you want
right away you begin
to see the differences between
funding X and funding Y,
the management, and so on.
Understanding if...
if you first need an investment fund
or an angel investor
will really make your life easier.
So, I'm going to change
the question a bit,
and answer this way.
What can I do to raise
the money I want?
Well, first you have to
have an idea,
a viable project,
something interesting.
Second, you have to know
what kind of money you want.
The characteristics of funding
like Performer
or like Monacir
is really specific.
You're going to talk to
another managing group
that will probably be looking
at different things
at different markets
at different-sized companies.
Don't you think?
But there are some things
that every investor looks for:
things like scalability,
a very good team of entrepreneurs
a market big and relevant enough
so that we can be sure
that it will grow a lot
and it'll be a good way
to make a lot of money.
At the end of the day, we invest in
what we're looking to invest in.
That is, we have
an investment theory
we look for opportunities that fit into
that investment theory.
So if your company or project fits into
our investment theory,
you're going to have to find a way
to get in touch with us.
It's events like these
you can look for me at the exit
and pick up a card.
You can look for
business plan competions
so you can show up where
we're always looking
always trying to participate.
And clearly, there's
a whole universe
of universities where there's always
a group of people
working with incubators
in the process of setting up companies-
lots of times entrepreneur workgroups
to create companies.
And we're always looking
and searching.
So if you don't know anyone directly
related to us
or if you project still
isn't ready to be...
to be visible where we'll see it
on the internet, in the media,
or some place like that,
you're going to have to try
to talk to us.
And then you'll have to have
a well-built arguement
a minimum plan of action.
I'm not saying a
complete business plan;
It's that you have a document where
you can explain to me what you want,
what you have
and what you hope to get.
And bring this
in a way that
it's attractive to the investor.
the art of Levit Peach.
You have to know how
to sell your product
even when
it's not yet ready.
If you aren't able
to make the sales pitch,
it's going to be real difficult to get
someone's attention. Like Eric said
in the traditional channels
of passive reception
we get hundreds
thousands of projects all the time.
And if you can't quickly demonstrate
that there's a difference,
that there's a different opportunity,
unfortunately, we're not going to
have time to read a lot of things -
and realize this at the end of day.
Bom, temos mais 10 minutos
e gostaría que vocês fizessem
perguntas se tiverem.
Tem um microfone aquí.
Não consigo ver muito bem,
então vou dar o microfone para
uma pessoa para fazer a pergunta.
Aonde quiser.
Tem um aquí na frente
Alô?
Está bom. Use o meu.
Da audiência #1: Devo perguntar
em inglês ou em português?
Dom: Inglês!
Que?
Não, português é melhor.
audience #1: OK.
About exporting a project
the the internet to gain visibility
to eventually prove a concept,
How can we deal with the fact
that exporting
the project and proving the concept
elevates the risk of a business
being copied tremendously,
due to the fact of sometimes being
very different from what exists?
Humberto: Oh! There are two things
there we have to separate...
one thing is when you have an idea.
The other is when you already
have a business.
When your company--
already structured--
is working,
it's going to make noise on the internet.
That's the kind of visibility we have
when we're investing
in an early-stage setup;
in other words, the business
has begun to work,
it's still not perfect,
sometimes the product isn't rounded out
but there's already a very clear
business opportunity.
It's another thing when
you're there on a project,
working on an idea,
getting a team together;
and then it's much more complicated
without a doubt.
It's one thing having a project run,
you've already put your foot to the ground
you've started up your work model
the whole market is watching
the work of a business
that makes it much easier
to finally protect that risk.
There's a natural competition
in any market,
but there's already some work
developing,
you're already exercising your
competitive will,
your first mover's advantage
for example.
When you are still
in the development stage,
obviously, you're not going to be
announcing to everyone,
Look, I've got an idea
I don't know how I'm going to do it,
but I want to capitalize on it.
So what can you do then?
If you structure it first,
develop that idea
and then find a way to contact --
if you need, in effect,
money before --
in other words,
you need an investor.
Now, probably, if you are not
at that stage,
you'll need an investor
or the money that you need
to make it happen;
you could probably raise it
from your family
from your friends or, eventually,
an angel investor.
They're very different models, aren't they?
Alex: So our website launches
new copy every day.
Literally, every day something else
hits the airwaves.
And we've benefitted a lot
by being first movers.
We've gotten
a lot of visibility.
It would take millions of reais
for to get that kind of visibility.
So, first pull your team together.
You and one or two people.
Get something working
something that's worth putting there.
Someone is going to put money into it
because it's working
and there it is
it's a good team,
people will invest.
They'll be interested in it.
Then you run
as fast as you can
don't stop when night falls
don't sleep, keep on going
7 days a week. Don't stop.
Then you'll start contracting, too.
You have to grab
the best people at the start,
because as you grow, you have to
establish a very good ethic
a very high level of professionalism
that we're always after
and, please, we're contracting
all levels of developers
with experience in DBA, infrastructure.
Send your resumé
to carreiras@[fisherbano],
because we're very interested
and we're contracting lots of people.
Eric: Let me finish up quickly.
I think there's something
very important.
Ideas are a commodity.
What's important is execution.
An idea is good,
it gives you a little advantage.
But like Alex said,
you're going to have to make it happen.
You always have to improve it.
And, on the internet,
the more innovative your idea,
you can be sure
that nobody will copy it
if you can't prove
that it's a business model. Nobody
wants to copy a business
that's not yet proven
You have some time at the start
the more innovative you are.
The more you've copied
an existing concept,
the more competition you'll have.
you have to be confident in yourself,
and put together a team
that has the skills,
the necessary abilities
to make it happen well.
And doing that
I mean its execution.
In the same way,
capital is also a commodity,
money is a commodity.
You have to see what comes with it,
what kind of investor
you're bringing to your business.
Ideas are also a business.
Lots of people come thinking
that the idea is everything.
No, an idea is the starting point.
Don: Outra pergunta aí.
audiencia #2: Here in the back.
I wanted to ask
that's not talking
if there's a forum
even if it's something
to your neighbor on a plane,
that's in other countries
that doesn't exist in Brazil,
I've always the problem,
for entrepreneurs to meet each other.
of finding a partner
for example,
so I'm not working all night
like I've done for two years,
programming by myself and saying
I can't take it anymore.
I'm only going to work 8 hours a day;
that's enough.
If that exists in some other country,
and if here in Brazil,
there's something like that
so that entrepreneurs can
meet each other.
exchange sketches and say
let's join forces...
three or four people
and work on a project?
Humberto: Look...
something organized,
you won't find.
We, at Performer,
are starting to set up
a product to address
just that kind of problem.
It's not a Performer investment fund.
It's really
a new division of Performer
where we're trying
to resolve this kind of problem for
those business that want to get started.
If it's bringing a business partner
to someone who's technical,
or an technical entrepreneur
with the opposite.
So in the same way that
we'll find a short while
to attract those entrepreneurs
who have a more technical profile,
we'll also try to attract entrepreneurs
with a more commercial profile,
more business-like
to try to do some matchmaking
and see if it turns out to be
an investment opportunity
for Performer.
Don: Outra pergunta?
audiencia #3: Humberto spoke
about significant markets.
I'd like to know which markets today
are important to developing software.
Eric: Who are you asking?
Humberto: Everyone, os dois.
Oh, good.
You really have two types of judgements
to make, don't you?
Significant
you can think that in the future
it'll be an interesting business,
there'll be a lot of money,
or you can think about
what giant problems exist
that nobody's solved, can't you?
I think that I'd give you
advice along these lines
so that you can measure it,
evaluate it.
Don't think only about technology itself.
Try to imagine the problem
that you want to solve
and calculate the pain that this problem
causes for your audience.
You want to deliver a solution
to that problem.
How much is that worth?
Understanding how much trouble
that problem is for your client
will give you an idea
of how much you can earn
fixing that problem for him.
Eric:
We have to remember,
we have to make
good choices
in the maketplace, don't we?
Going back to the topic I spoke of earlier
that investors are looking for
businesses that can be large,
so they have to operate
in big markets.
So you have to think
choose that marketplace well.
Given that in Brazil you sometimes
see an idea overseas that's interesting
but it's an idea
that's tucked within a sector
but that overseas sector
is very big;
For example,
the U.S. economy is big;
it's a business that has
an international reach.
And when you apply that
the corresponding market in Brazil,
the market...
the crux of that idea
ends up being very small
and you'll never grow a big company.
Now, you can also bet
on a trend.
The risk is higher
and you can say
Look, this market doesn't exist today,
but it will exist, and
the money will have to
transfer from somewhere.
You have to understand that dynamic.
But it's important to look
not only at the product,
not only at the user.
Sometimes you have a business
that resolves a user's problem
but doesn't have
as much economic value.
That's when your business knowledge
your vision, trend analysis
comes into play;
both strategies.
I think that entrepreneurs
have a strong feeling for,
a strong intuition about these things.
But you have to have that ability
on your team.
Don: Temos tempo para mais uma?
Mais uma pergunta.
audiencia #4: Good evening.
My name is Luis Fernando.
My question is that
sometimes I see a lot of people
who want to open a business
but they already
have a job.
And mostly they end up
working all day and night
to not leave or let go of
their current job
because of the risk.
Because opening a business
is a risky thing, too, and the question is
do you think that
that's a winning strategy
or do you think that someone
should go in with head bowed,
resign their job, and dedicate
themselves only to that?
Alex: I think you have to live
just like that...
Your life has to be
that business.
Now, to get there
to test things out,
you can do things after work
you can test things out and see
how that business will be for you.
But as soon as you've decided,
that you've seen potential,
you should resign and invest
100 percent in it.
Eric: OK, wrapping up!
We, for example,
don't ever consider a situation where
investing or analyzing
investment in an idea
that's part-time
for an entrepreneur.
We only believe in it
when the entrepreneur's there 100%
of the time, totally
dedicated to it.
That's fundamental.
Like Alex said
it's possible to test it out.
But you'd be surprised
how many times we've seen
proposals and ideas
from groups that want to
set up a business and still keep
to control the risk
it doesn't exist.
I mean,
if the entrepreneur takes a risk,
Venture Capital takes the risk.
He's talking about risk,
a controlled risk,
a conscious risk
but high risk
high return.
Humberto: At the end of the day,
if you're afraid of doing it,
I'm going to be even more afraid.
Now if you believe that you have
that it has to turn out right,
I can believe that, too.
So, if you don't give me that guarantee
that you believe in it,
that it's going to turn out right,
I'm going to say, Look,
come back when you're sure.
Don: Está bom.
Bem, acabou o tempo.
Mas estaremos aquí, lá fora, por
uma meia hora ou uma hora.
Vem falar com a gente.
Muito obrigado por ter vindo
e ter escutado tudo.
Obrigado.
[Aplausos.]
00:37:35.400,00:00:00.000